[Music]
you guys might be wondering why it's
been so long since we uploaded something
to the main channel well we've been
shooting something called sync for the
past two months sync is a web series
we've been working on and if you haven't
seen it check it out it's a huge 12
episode web series and it's nuts you
guys have been asking for a bigger
project from us so here it is anyways
now that we're all done shooting it it's
off in the hands of editors music guys
sound guys we have a lot more free time
now now that we're not shooting it
anymore so you guys can look forward to
a video every two weeks just like the
good old days until the end of time
until
we get killed until the internet is shut
down by old men who don't understand
youtube so i bet you guys are wondering
how did we come up with the idea for
this crazy video well we're actually
working on another video unfortunately
things started falling apart we realized
wait a second we need to make a video
right now at the last second we only got
a couple hours so we took a look at what
we had we realized wait a second you can
do motion capture with an xbox connect
so we took that idea when we ran with it
and we started doing some animation
tests started getting some little dance
animations and they're so funny that we
realized wait a second
we have to make a whole video just about
us dancing as miniature figurines after
going out to the warehouse and dancing
around and staring at nothingness with
our cg goggles
we came back and started the process for
this video
one really cool thing about it is that
pretty much the entire the entire effect
is done with an automated process uh we
start with the connect and we
automatically get motion capture data
for our actual dance moves and then we
move on to our bodies which we created
using a program called one two three d
catch terrible name great program but uh
we used that to construct a 3d model
based off of composite images that we
took in a 360 degree circle of ourselves
and then for our faces and face models
we used a program called face gen which
will automatically create a
very similar looking 3d model of your
face based off of three photos it's not
perfect but it gets the job done no hair
though so kind of have to do this one
bald and the face gen heads comes with
something comes with something called a
morph target where uh basically gives
you all the different expressions and
you can link those to the model and then
you just mark between them to get your
different facial expressions so that's
how i made little munchkin guys going
and stuff oh here's something cool
there's one shot when the whole group of
guys begin to dance believe it or not
that shot is 100 cg there's not a real
element in that shot even though it
looks like a real concrete floor and
real people in the background it is
entirely virtual
so for those of you guys out there who
want to try to do the same thing
basically plug your connect into your
computer uh there's a program that we
use called reckle connect um basically
you load that up record your animation
you save it out as a bvh file which is
like a universal motion capture file in
3ds max you create a biped and you can
load that as motion capture data on the
biped that's basically all there is to
it um there's some small nuances here
and there if you just you know mess
around with it you'll probably figure it
out
you guys are always welcome to tweet at
us with any questions if you're trying
it out at corridor digital so good luck
you